sheltering from the sun in chad's
capital in jamina the hometown kosari is
just 20 kilometers away in northern
cameroon
all were forced to cross the border
after seeing what they say was some of
the worst fighting yet between fishing
and herding communities over access to
water supplies
the fighting in cusary has been very
violent we had to cross the river at
night to find refuge here
now that we are safe you face the cold
weather and lack of food our children
have not eaten since yesterday we asked
the chadian authorities to help us
otherwise our situation here will be
worse than the conflict we have at home
on wednesday youth set fire to a cattle
market belonging to a rival community it
retaliated several people were killed
and many others were wounded
we left in a rush crossed the river at
our own risk without taking anything now
we are exposed to the elements the dust
and the cold the children are at risk of
becoming ill we ask for urgent help
help is what chad's president is calling
for he's tweeted an urgent appeal for
the international community to send aid
as soon as possible as chad struggles to
cope with an influx of more than 30 000
refugees from both cameroon and
neighbouring sudan the un's refugee
agency says violence last month in sudan
has displaced thousands of people many
sudanese women and children are now in
chat
the armed group didn't ask us anything
they just attacked and shot us
the majority of the half a million
refugees in chad are from sudan
the ongoing fight little rain and pest
infestation have all disrupted the
farming season in the darfur region
that's increasing concerns of worsening
food shortages which are threatening to
force more people to flee into chad
sarojarat al jazeera